die bundeswehr braucht dringend neue it
experten und auch echte hacker problemen
die richtig guten leute trainer freien
wirtschaft damals war nachgeguckt bis zu
120000 euro einstiegsgehalt im jahr wäre
ungefähr 1 generals soll
wir schalten darüber nach bonn zu
oberstleutnant sebastian pufpaff vom
neuen cyber kommando abrufbar wo kriegen
sie denn jetzt die ganzen leute her
nicht leicht bewölkt der hacker an sich
ist ein scheues reh ein viertes
bitterböse faule dickel bratzel
da muss man anreize schaffen also haben
wir und das ist kein witz als erste
bundeswehreinheit überhaupt flexible
arbeitszeiten eingeführt und morgen an
feldwebel künast einrichten konnten
ich freue mich wenn man mit den vögeln
hätte sich hitler bei kriegs anfang die
kugel gegeben aber durch die zukunft da
muss man reagieren
nur in diesem jahr schon 284.000
angriffe auf bundeswehr rechner ja nur
mal so interesse aber welche geheimnisse
könnte meinen bei der bundeswehr clown
die baupläne für das g36
zum beispiel die betriebe
wir müssen unsere netzwerke rund um die
uhr schutz
ich lasse gerade eine neue firewall
einrichten
jetzt möchte ich mal sehen wie der russe
den rechner findet bis neulich an die
drecksäcke aus moskau durch die
hintertür auf unseren rechnern windows
98 installiert was sie nicht wussten
vorher live über windows 2000 oder
gelesen ihre abteilung dürfen
ausländische netzwerk auch angreifen
vertrete ich das eigentlich mit dem
auftrag unserer bundeswehr
ja klar es ist doch gerade das geile
diese burschen von marine heer und
luftwaffe
die spielen doch nur krieg die lern
höchstens wie man regionalzug folkerts
bei uns im netz dagegen bei uns ist gott
verdammter krieg meine jungs treten im
iran in den virtuellen verstehe also
richtig kaffee ganz genau weiß auf delta
force ist es und klavier wir sind hier
die 9b des marler fa cup in juárez mit
bedeutungslosen inklusive familien und
erschwerniszulage allein unsere
aufnahmerituale viel brutaler als jede
andere waffengattung jeder neue rekrut
muss sämtliche krümmel vogel und popel
aussetzers dazu seines vorgängers einmal
wir wollen die härtesten der euro
klettere auf 1 ab der ruß begreifen was
an bemüht sehr gut sebastian wurth mal
damen und herren wir singen deutschland
[Applaus]